genetic engineering is not a bad thing
because even if it were it's not going
to go away um I have geneticist friends
who have no barriers whatsoever moving
from conventional breeding which means
we're using a microscope Ben we're
taking genetics out of one thing and
putting it in another thing that's
conventional breeding whereas we're
bombarding something with radiation from
something else and splicing genes and
doing all kinds of nanotechnology they
have no trouble walking back and forth I
don't think that genetic engineering is
a bad thing if we know its impact and I
think that just as much on the
conventional so i can raise issues about
invasive species on a conventional basis
that are more deleterious bamboo we all
love bamboo don't we it is a threat in
the south because of just people
planting it just for fun well it never
goes away you can dig a hundred feet
down it's still there we have weedy rice
in the South that's still there from
before the civil war that took down rice
fields where you can't farm the rice
fields so I have examples that are every
bit as deleterious is what we might
imagine from genetic engineering that
have been here continuously for our
existence here in America certainly and
so I could say do I want to focus on
genetic engineering the answers I don't
at all I don't have time am I kind of
leery of it yes I am I'm I was trained
in the sciences as a college student so
I'm concerned about the long-term
processes and how we evaluate this and
whether the evaluation is thorough or
whether we are trying to satisfy a
profit motive in a business string I'm
sensitive to that by the same token I
think that there are things being done
in research that maybe be rushing maybe
could be perceived as rushing the
results to put it in lay terms
you